OptiKey is a piece of software that I've developed for Windows.
When paired with an eye tracking device,...
...it allows you full computer control and speech generation using only your eyes.
It's designed for people with motor and speech limitations,...
...specifically people with motor neuron disease or ALS.
OptiKey is free, a hundred percent.
It's fully free, fully open source forever.
I decided very early on that this wasn't gonna be a profit-making exercise.
I had an aunt who died about four and a bit years ago from motor neuron disease,...
...and I sort of took two things away from the whole experience.
One was how horrible these sort of degenerative diseases can be.
And the second thing was that the solutions available to help people communicate...
...as they're losing their faculties and losing control of their body,...
...they're either sort of insufficient or they're very, very expensive.
And that struck me as being fiercely unfair...
...and I thought I had a shot of doing something about it.